all right I want to just do this right
at the top of the show today and get it
out of the way I don't want it to turn
into a big controversy and I just want
to be ideologically and morally
consistent here Bernie Sanders
previously said he would release all of
his medical records his full medical
records and now he's saying that he's
not going to and I believe that he
should do it I believe it shouldn't be
any huge thing that divides the left
there is a reason not to vote for Bernie
or anything like that at this point this
is a Biden Budaj edge
Bernie race I believe there is one
progressive there it's Bernie that's who
I'm voting for in the primary and that's
it but Bernie Sanders has criticized
Donald Trump for saying he'd release his
taxes and never doing it Bernie promised
to release his full medical records
before the first votes were cast the
first votes were cast last Monday in
Iowa more votes are coming tonight in
New Hampshire there are a ton of people
making this about things that it's not a
way to attack Bernie or about double
standards or whatever I don't care about
any of that stuff I'm voting for Bernie
in the primary but he promised he would
release his full medical records no one
made him promise that he chose to do
that to make that promise he said in
November that releasing his health
records quote it's the right thing to do
the American people have a right to know
whether the person they're going to be
voting for for president is healthy he
said it a number of times during
interviews here is one of course the
people do have a right to know about the
health of a senator and somebody's
running for president the unites full
full disclosure and we will make it at
the appropriate time all of our medical
records public for you for anybody else
who wants to see them he was asked on
Meet the Press this weekend if he would
do it and now he says he would not that
he's released enough and that he's
healthy um the first votes have already
been cast you did not release your
medical record you read well you
released a few letters
nobody interviewed your doctors you did
have a heart attack apparently shouldn't
voters see your medical records it's
much documentation I think as any other
candidate but no other candidates had a
heart attack well look I am no one the
candidate is doing four or five events a
day run
here's country no you have you even I
mean no doubt you've proven your mettle
here but boaters you heard voters have
been concerned about you can thought
releasing medical records and never ends
we have released a substantive pot of
all of our background we have doctors
who have cardiologists who are
confirming that I am in good health I am
in good health what changes have you did
the doctor has asked you to make that
you've made I'm trying to walk a little
bit more but the schedule doesn't allow
me they didn't say they did so I'm not
making this anything more than what it
is when I tweeted people I tweeted
yesterday asking since Bernie promised
it do you think he should do it and I
got some messages from people saying
this is a really cheap way of smearing
Bernie because you don't like him or
whatever I'm voting for him in the
primary okay I see people saying on
Twitter to me Trump never released his
taxes so why does Bernie have to release
his medical records well he doesn't have
to but saying that the standard is now
what Donald Trump does is silly when
we're arguing that were better than
Donald Trump Bernie said he would do it
and he should plain and simple now
there's another angle the other angle is
well other candidates released letters
from their doctors and Bernie released
letters from his doctors and that's it
again Bernie said he'd release his full
medical records and he hasn't done it do
we care do you care are we going to be
consistent that's really what the issue
is here Elizabeth Warren released a
number of different things she released
documents that included a doctor's note
but it included hematology reports
chemistry reports a whole bunch of stuff
vice president released a doctor's
report in December and it is less than
what Elizabeth Warren released Bernie
said he'd released everything and he's
out saying he's not going to do it now I
I don't want to be morbid I don't want
to do anything other than what seems
logical here but it's widely known that
when white men in their 70s I mean it
you know it applies to all races but not
but you know I'm just mentioning because
we're talking about Bernie when might
white men in their 70s have a heart
attack that has an effect on life
expectancy there are a lot of studies
about life expectancy after
heart attacks and I I hope that people
are realizing this isn't Hillary
Parkinson's stuff there are just real
medical facts that I wish weren't true
but when AI believe then 77 year old has
a heart attack the academic research
points to this is it's important that
full record medical records be made
available period so let's not excuse
this because it's Bernie and it's not
Trump's taxes or Trump's bogus medical
letter Trump should release his taxes
Trump should actually subject himself to
real rigorous medical examination that
he clearly needs and Bernie should
release what he said he would release
period if you disagree with me let me
know for me this is very cut and dry and
it doesn't really require any more
conversation than the four minutes I've
devoted to it today
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now
I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free they
do have a paid version with different
tiers where you can create more virtual
credit card numbers per month cash back
rewards extra security features but go
ahead and sign up for the
free service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly you're
protected from identity theft that costs
you nothing and privacy is giving you
five dollars to spend just for signing
up when you go to privacy calm slash
Pakman